[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
Mark Ellis joined as always by the
incredible Jacqueline Coley who just has
such a beautiful smile on that signifies
she's almost at the end of awards he's
that is exactly what that is your
busiest time of the year your tax season
I know and honestly just as oppressive
but it's like whatever you can't be mad
about it but it is a lot no it's me
you're coming to the end of the season
you're coming to the end of a very long
movie you're just coming to the end of a
thing that you had embarked on so a
journey yeah we're gonna be talking
about a journey in this show and I
particularly want to thank both you and
our special guest Matt nost uh for this
episode of the podcast because I had
such a great workout this morning
because I watched our movie again last
night how is this part of my intro
dominating the back courts of Rec
leagues here in Los Angeles the
municipal County rec league b league but
today we're talking about Rocky IV and I
watched that last night I watched the
director's cut for the first time ever
it was so extra credit Rocky Ford it
never fails to give I think maybe I'll
just limit it to Men of a certain age
but probably a lot of people juice when
it comes to I need to get back in the
gym this movie does it just about as
well as anything okay the 38 extra
minutes how many more montages
this thing already has I love it there's
one Montage that ends and then there's a
scene between Rocky and Adrian and then
he goes boom right back into Montage so
you're taking that 38 minutes if we get
at least two more proof that what what
what is life it's just the moments in
between montages the director's Cut Is
apparently 93 minutes the the actual the
original Rocky IV which is the movie
we're going to be talking about Ad
nauseam today I might get into some
where the director's cut is different
but we want to focus on Rocky IV the OG
Rocky IV that is 91 minutes so it's only
two minutes longer there's a lot of
stuff that they took out and they put
back in other things that weren't seen
in the original one so there's a lot
here if you're a fan of the Rocky 4
robot we're talking about the Rocky IV
version that does have the robot in it
that's the good news the bad news is
unfortunately the movie's 37 rotten on
the Tomato Meter when we had our book a
few years ago the right movies we love
release it was 40 and somehow it's gone
down another three percent the audience
is a little closer to where at least
some folks on this panel lie 79 of the
audience but 37 rotten is Rocky 4 from
1985 mattost your special guest today
you're a celebrated comedian catch him
when he's on tour uh he's also again
deadly three-point shot we also have
this great trivia sensation you've
created on YouTube called settle the
score where every week you have two
movie enthusiasts a lot of pundits in
this space some celebrity guests they
try to guess the score that your buddy
Andy is playing on the piano and it's
from a movie three rounds and so I
figured you're an expert on rounds and
judging rounds we have for you for Rocky
four way to tie that back in I didn't
know if I was gonna get there but there
we are so I put the question to you you
always make your guests settle the score
I'm gonna make you say is the score here
right or wrong is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
what are we talking about we're talking
critical score 37 on the tomatoes that
just means it's that 63 hate America
that's what that means I I salute this
movie listen how many movies do you know
brought down a political ideology
because this helped in communism yes it
did it did I agree it did uh Jacqueline
Cole I'll go to you next is Rotten
Tomatoes right or wrong about 37 for 24.
I I don't know because like I do feel
they're right but I also feel they're
wrong so like I was like I was like yes
this is exactly the thing I want to say
because I absolutely do feel that Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong about this movie
because it is a movie that like begs an
emotional response and you can't deny
that it is a movie that if the purpose
of filmmaking and moving Motion Pictures
is to implant emotions or ideas into the
minds of the audience you can't say it
doesn't like complete that tenfold but
Lord it is like this camptastic just so
cheesy 80s with barely a plot just
laughable villains
laughable villains laughable in their
archetypes like this is like these are
just like come borders and Natasha level
of death
I mean this is the movie version of The
Adventures of bowinkle I mean it is not
deep but it doesn't have to be that deep
it does not have to be that deep but it
is not and so I have a hard time
if you want to call it an enjoyable time
it's certified fresh if you want to call
it Cinema I gotta go with the critics
like I feel in between which is why I
have such a problem with this being
rotten on the Tomato Meter because you
say if it lacks depth or it's not that
it it's not that complicated neither is
boxing all right it's boxing it's like
I'm gonna get in a ring with somebody
and whoever walks out of it is probably
going to be declared the winner and so
here you have the ultimate test it's a
Redemption story it's about friendship
it's about moving on it's about
realizing that you can't do one thing
forever in life and you gotta pivot
sometimes and sometimes you just gotta
suck it up and have a great incredible
life-changing Sports training montage
but I don't think you can hold this
movie up to saying is it Cinema because
it was never intended to be it wasn't
intended to be Cinema but it used to do
a passable version of at least giving
the characters both more depth and more
themes and look first of all like again
you killed my friend and I'm coming for
vengeance I'm not asking on Christmas
I'm not asking for a lot that is
literally the same plot of John Wick but
you can add more to it it was the peak
of of sort of 80s American machismo and
because Stallone and Schwarzenegger this
time were like the two of the biggest
movie stars on the planet you know
Schwarzenegger coming off Terminator and
he was about to blow up in movies like
predator and you had Stallone with the
Rambo franchise and with the Rockies and
they just kept going this was probably
the Rocky movie where they're like oh
we're just gonna keep getting these
movies every so often but we didn't and
they took an interesting turn afterwards
so this is a very interesting point in
the Rocky mythology so we want to get to
a lot of Rocky IV talk obviously but I
also want to relate this movie to the
other Rockies which one stands the
tallest including the Creed movies
because Creed 3 comes out I believe
tomorrow as of this uh this recording or
maybe the next week so Jack and I've
seen Creed 3 we might give you a little
sneak uh previous to our thoughts but
let's get into a couple editorial shout
outs first before we get to two minutes
with Tim all the Rocky and the Creed
movies are ranked according to our
experts on rottentomatoes.com so you can
check that out you might be surprised at
the number one movie Creed is number one
Rocky IV is number seven and if you
think that's too low Matt you're really
not gonna like this news
rottentomatoes.com also has the 33 best
boxing movies of all time Rocky Ford did
not make the list
of the bone
I don't know where to play it to the
Bone landed well I will say on both
those lists those are based on critical
opinion it's not like what we call our
Essentials because we sometimes do these
lists where it's like these are the
movies if you are trying to watch boxing
movies you need to watch all of these
which should be rotten or fresh these
ones are just the top rated so Rocky 4
at 39 that'd be a pretty weak list okay
three snuck in there it was it's fresher
yes it is yes it is a high bar for that
I think the highest one is 85. but if if
you look at the top 33 movies according
to this list uh you do get some Rocky 4
in it because Creed 2 is in the top 33.
updated version of this yeah a lot of
connective tissue and then obviously one
more mention for our wonderful book uh
the right movies we love you can get
that wherever you enjoy books and so
right now before we get into our movie
talk segment we are going to toss it to
our good friend Tim Ryan he does our
segment two minutes with Tim he's going
to tell you what the critics were saying
about this movie when it came back way
back at the height of the Cold War 1985.
look nobody here is going to strenuously
deny that in its best moments Rocky IV
is pretty awesome even if it's often
Preposterous Cold War propaganda it's
hard not to root for Rocky in the
undeniably exciting final match against
Ivan Drago however awesome as it can be
Rocky IV also has a number of issues
that even fans are likely to acknowledge
like it's utter predictability or the
excessive use of footage from the first
three movies or the hometown Soviet
crowd switching allegiances in mid-fight
or the robot Butler which has a real
life backstory that's pretty poignant
but still that said a lot of folks love
this movie partly because of those
elements not in spite of them but it's
hard not to see why critics back in 1985
were less than impressed particularly
given the high standards set by the
original Rocky less than a decade before
Rocky IV is rotten at 37 on the Tomato
Meter with 49 reviews and it has a 79
audience score so what do the critics
have to say in a rotten view Roger Uber
to the Chicago Sun Times wrote even
Sylvester Stallone seems to be getting
tired of the series as the writer and
director as well as the star he puts
himself through the same old Paces
however in a fresh review Gene Siskel
the Chicago Tribune wrote that Stallone
creates credible villains worthy of his
heroic character the Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus reads Rocky IV
inflates the action to absurd Heights
But ultimately Rings Hollow thanks to a
story that hits the same basic beats as
the first three entries in the franchise
so that's Rocky IV let's kick it back to
Jacqueline and Mark if they can change
and you can change everybody can change
thank you Tim and a lovely sentiment to
leave us with there in the words of the
Rocky IV robot to you Tim happy birthday
Paulie let's get right into movie talk
here hit the music Brian
[Music]
foreign
first of all I have an update on the 33
best boxing movies of all time play it
to the Bone did not make the list it is
sitting at 11 on the Tomato Meter Matt
you are welcome to come back on the show
when we have our planet to the Bone
episode not gonna happen I'll join the
Critics on that do we have a
garbage show I was all joined that show
you can you are allowed to say Rotten
Tomatoes is right although with us you
know we tend to disagree with this
particular tomato eater score let me go
back to the first time that young Matt
knows heard of the name Rocky Balboa you
were aware of this franchise because
like to me growing up it was always you
talk about the Rocky movies and like
talk about them with like my dad and
it's like wait wait it's three the one
with the Russian guy or is that with Mr
T you really know the names of anybody
this knew Rocky was fighting something
impossible uh I think the first one I
might have seen was three because of the
Hulk Hogan aspect that was huge into
wrestling like a bunch of kids my age
yeah but this movie four ties in with
all those themes because that was a lot
of wrestling which is USA so to see that
on the big screen I was like this is
amazing did you see it in theaters uh
yeah I saw Rocky I was a little kid I
was six and you saw Rocky four in a
movie theater you saw Rocky Ford in a
movie okay so our our mutual friend a
wonderful comedian Steve Simone from
Philadelphia I should point that out
right off the bat he's from Philly he
went to go see this like opening weekend
with his entire family in Philadelphia
he said the crowd stood up and cheered
yes like multiple times during the drugs
they turned an action movie into a box
it was Philly it was probably a nice
cross section because you got to
remember Rockies because I'm just
picturing right into Philly but let's be
real depending on the theme
it's it's very good at appealing to a
wide swath of demographic because you
have obviously the Rocky Balboa story
well that is not their vibe in the
theater is my point like you go into a
movie theater or something like Rocky
yes I think it's that's more if there
are other movies no no I'm basically
what I'm saying is if the movie could
Inspire the never make noise in the
theater crowds of most establishments to
all of a sudden decide to get into a
dialogue this is Cinema I agree the next
year white people probably had a good
run with Top Gun but but nothing like
Rocky IV and you don't have to believe
me or Matt or Steve or anybody you can
just go watch Eddie Murphy Raw and see
what he does about white guys leaving a
Rocky movie and thinking they're
Invincible this is a different vibe I do
feel like there's a different vibe in
this movie I think that there it is I
felt it I felt it so did you just go as
six-year-old Matt knows did you just
like charge out of the theater pumped up
uh I'm waving an American flag all those
things that I was already you know going
off the top turnbuckle with my brother
at home so it just fed into the just uh
ah the rage you have as a six year old
yeah so just fed into that quite
beautifully and uh yeah it's cemented
it's hands down my favorite Rock he
still is to this day so Jacqueline you
were aware of the rocky franchise when
I was aware of the rocky franchise early
just because of Apollo Creed and Carl
Weathers okay like he was very popular
and so I think the I think the
I want to say the second Rocky where
they rematch was the first one that I
ever remember seeing and it was like
probably like a TNT like rerun basically
and I know I was like way older you know
whatever I think I came out I think I
was born like when the third one came
out anyway but Mr T that was like the
first one where I was like really into
it because Mr T was scary in that movie
yes he was he was like a legitimate like
super villain and that to me also had
that like wrestling element to it like
that that really like solidified both of
those for me right and then you have
rocky five and then the the franchise
just sort of ends and is in the doldrums
for 15 years until Rocky Balboa comes
out and then we have this Resurgence
again with Creed in 2015 which got great
critical reviews and made a crap ton of
money now we have a new franchise to
celebrate again one that does tie back
to a lot of the things that we see in
Rocky IV so you know it's it's a hard
thing to kick off with but like as
Jacqueline pointed out Matt she she
feels like if you're just looking at
this with a critical eye the movie
should be 37 percent but just like as
somebody watching a fun movie you love
it is this a bad movie that you just
think is good to watch I just I think we
all look at different movies through
different prisms so you go into this one
not going cinema verite this is gonna
blow me away I can't wait for all the
subtext although there is some weird
stuff in this one upon rewatch that I
never noticed before like what uh like
the opening Fight The Living in America
that whole sequence there's a lot of
pagan symbolism it seems like there's a
bull
there's a bull that comes down and it
transforms into a Creed dies and he's in
a christ-like pose as Rocky is holding
him but for some reason Paulie has uh a
torch but the skull is at the top of the
torch it hasn't been lit yet did you put
on temple of doom by accident no trust
me go back and watch it I remember the
bowl I remember why is there a bull
there's there's no and it did it well
the one thing I do know is they were
basing that moment off of James Brown's
stage shows at the time did he have a
bull honestly he had like all kinds of
crazy because I saw that so he did have
all kinds of crazy stuff and I do
remember animals were a part of it I
don't know if it was a bull it's a huge
Bowl I don't know if it was a bull but
like the because James is singing his
song Living in America for this one that
whole stage show like that whole thing
that was just James at the time he was
known for those types of shows well then
that's me reading because then the the
christ-like and Madonna I was like well
is that supposed to be doing that Pagan
I don't know if it appears with the
Pagan but I do agree with you it was a
christ-like pose yeah like that yeah
it's the whole cradle in his arms and
for some reason they allow every
reporter into the ring immediately like
I've never seen that oh if you if you
look at the the first fight that we see
in Rocky IV and which is which is the
exhibition match this was supposed to be
an exhibition between Drago Coming to
America and uh you know Apollo creep
cause Rocky didn't take the fight so now
Apollo Creed can kind of step in and
Apollo Creed can use this as a
springboard to be back to relevance
because he hasn't been a professional
boxer in five years he's been retired so
they get in the ring and it is amazing
because that's where the punch gets
thrown early in the second round it
kills Apollo Creed he's dying in the
ring every reporter runs in there
they're interviewing Drago the winner
and Rocky is holding Apollo Crete's head
and I gotta think after watching recent
NFL weeks like this is the worst sort of
protocol yeah health-wise to save this
man's life the doctor can't get to him
yeah just surrounds us holding his head
yeah it's one of those things where at
best you would think maybe they didn't
realize he was dead in that moment or
was hoping that you know he could be
revived but that's like the best case
scenario and they knew he was dead like
there was like he was already like I
think you know they do like he's doing
it he does he dies
somebody is a Zeus there and that would
be Ivan Drago and so that's real we
didn't do the synopsis at the beginning
because we kind of think you so Apollo
Creed dies it's become Rocky's best
friend former Rivals now about BFFs he
kills him so that's gonna Inspire Rocky
to go to Russia on Christmas day to
fight in a non-sanctioned match he
couldn't get the sanctioning so he has
to give up his heavyweight title that he
currently owns just to go fight this guy
in Russia to get revenge training
sequences ensue and then we have our
final fight definitely and two of the
greatest
Montage Songs laying atop them yes Eye
of the Tiger which was already a hard
thing to top let's be real the movie
kicks off without a tiger Where Do We Go
From Here Yeah you only go up thanks to
No Easy Way Out by Robert Tepper and
then as Matt pointed out five six
minutes later Hearts on Fire by John
Cafferty and you just are so ready to
climb a literal mountain in the snow
which is what Rocky ends up doing so
does he because they do close-up shots
of Stallone where you can kind of tell
he's at an incline and then the super
wide shots of some dude in the same
outfit I love that they cut back to
Let's uh they're Stallone and wide shot
where he's this big yeah Sam he's
yelling Drago so if if we're looking at
the movie as a whole Jacqueline do you
have a favorite scene is it one of the
training montages is it something else
that sticks out to you you know in all
honesty I really enjoy watching Ivan
Drago's torture through his training
sessions like the other side of it so it
is a montage session but specifically
yeah Ivan Drago's like the most
perfectly trained family ever exactly
and it really like I just love the
Demonic nature of them like you know
like you know checking his punch power
and then like Bridget Nielsen as his
like basically like emotional translator
in all of this too like like it was so
great to see her character it was a it
was like an interesting juxtaposition to
what we'd seen with Ty Shire all the way
yeah also I loved all of the opulence of
Rocky's surroundings sure and just
showing again like how One of the sort
of conceits of even the very first Rocky
is like the worst thing to happen to a
boxer a success nobody gets out of bed
at 5am when they got silk sheets is that
Marvin Hagler I believe
I do love that that juxtaposition of the
training between Rocky and Drago because
that is going back to Rocky's Roots
where look he he's just this this you
know Club fighter Out of Philly yeah he
doesn't have he doesn't have the
resources that a a legendary figure like
Apollo Creed has he's got at the rocky
gym and you and I and Comics who always
talk about like just getting into a dark
comedy club where that's kind of the
rocky gym it's not the fancy life yeah
yeah you're literally punching meat and
then we have Drago and if this movie
could possibly get any more 80s it does
when we see the steroid needle go into
his butt so there's just so much good in
this movie Matt can you boil it down to
the scene that you say that that's why I
keep coming back for more from the Rocky
4 well well first off Stallone made some
excellent choices directing I will say
that he directed during the montages so
the juxtaposition between the two you've
got drunk on one side and all the people
that are monitoring him and it's all
very clinical and then you go to Rockies
and if any of these two generals are
roided up it's clearly Stallone
absolutely especially when they take
that at the end yeah whoa the first time
they take their robes off and you can
just tell he's flexing every abductor
muscle that he has his course like okay
you don't get that as a guy your size
but anyway
the the two the two training montages my
favorite are all the people around Rocky
is he's doing this stuff they all
individually have a shot where it cuts
to them and they go
they're just nodding yes nodding yeah
for no reason as he's like
he's doing it he's done it yeah as
somebody that that tries to get in the
gym as much as I can and like lift
weights now when you watch those
training sequences it's like dude you're
gonna you're gonna hurt yourself
something oh my God I just just thought
of that because like I do it now too
which by the way let's be real there's
nothing about the ridiculously small
amount of workout I do and the obscene
amount of bitching I do through it that
like relates to what Rocky's doing
fine no I told that dude the reason why
I pay you is not to make me work out
it's to listen to me as I work out
but anyway Rocky Face those guys used to
nod their head exactly
somebody do at least I've seen
tangentially someone like transform
their body it's not like that it's just
doing this a lot you know it's like like
you know like it's just like a lot of
bench work like there's some like this
stuff is really like they're being very
extra in the in the workout it's like no
we don't want you to live something
we're gonna make you chase a chicken
like just run well the thing with Rocky
is like I understand you want to get
back to Nature and you just want to
train like you want to get that farm
strength back and that's why you go to
this remote Mountain location
you have money yeah he has money to
spend on a gym instead he's like just
give me a barn and they're like okay
what sort of equipment he's like I don't
want any equipment just give me a barn
with another story so I can do sit-ups
up to it give me an ox yoke that I can
do this for some reason I realize that
they're doing this I'm like this is dumb
almost down in Hawaii dude and you will
still be working out are you trying to
pull Poly on that sled and they go over
to Drago Drago's using the machine but
thereby utilizing on the muscles and you
see Rocky who's like one foot struggle
fall and you're like how is this
building up the muscle the more I think
it's supposed to be about repetition of
action you know the more it meets
resistance and yours is just falling
down resistance but it like I I do
wonder if this was a real sporting event
that happened and there's like those
Services you can get a celebrity like
tell you like happy birthday or
something like on Cameo I would pay top
dollar for Steven A Smith just to have
him react to this match if Rocky did in
fact the lose because maybe it's your
training methods maybe it's the fact and
I never this never clipped with me until
I I watched it last night and I'm pretty
sure it's mentioned but maybe glossed
over more in the original cut is that
they they tell him as soon as he gets to
his compound in Russia they're like oh
by the way you're not allowed to have
any sparring partners and they're like
what I don't remember them saying that
we're not allowed to have yeah so it's
like a bit it's like you cannot bring in
any fighters to spar with so now Drago
can Spar knockout whoever he wants Rocky
has nobody to spar with so that's why
he's just walking in the mountains by
himself he's got no friends I love it it
is ridiculous leather Sherpa lined
jacket this whole outfit I couldn't tell
if those were jeans or sweatpants he's
wearing it's just fly in Clubber Lang
you know damn by what I said and this is
a camp picture Rocky doing this this way
is literally like Nathan Lane in the
bird cage pretending that he's not gonna
go on and so he's like literally like
it's gonna be like this like this is out
this is so cute but that's what makes it
we're gonna put on a show and we have to
show them how hard we worked and we're
gonna make it Butch ladies and gentlemen
it's gonna be ice and yoke
but you do see throughout this movie you
see how much of a friendship Rocky and
Apollo Creed had built I think that's
like a real thing in this movie is based
on his training to fight clubber Wang in
the rematch that was spearheaded by
Apollo Creed because he's like dude you
the way you were training that's not how
you beat Clubber Lang you got to let me
teach you some stuff that you don't know
so they go to La and that's where they
like race on the beach and stuff and so
we see a lot of those callbacks in the
montages and Rocky IV but I do like how
it made this movie is so important to
the Creed franchise and that's maybe one
of the reasons why I feel like we need
to get this Tomato Meter back up to
Fresh because we don't get Creed without
this because you see how strong the
fiber of friendship is between Apollo
and Rocky and that's why somebody like
honest Creed in the first movie Creed
can show up to Rocky's restaurant
another generation later and be like hey
I'm gonna literally guilt-trip you yeah
into training me because you let my dad
die in the ring I mean and it worked let
me let's be and it would it would work
on me it would work on you because like
absolutely you could couldn't be
heartless but honestly I figured out a
way to make this happen to get to the 40
okay
I think what a low bar just get back to
forty percent I should get this out here
no 60. that seems like a low threshold I
mean we could at least get to 40 maybe I
think I can maybe do that because in all
honestly the more you were talking about
these male friendships I'm just my
fanfic brain is working like I could see
a a story where it is Rocky who has this
secret love affair with Apollo Creed and
then Drago kills him in the ring and so
then Rocky wants to fight him in the
ring but then he realizes through the
fight that they really love each other
like this is a fan fiction waiting to be
written yeah but this seems like a Ben
Hur Charlie
about the game
literally like I really do feel like
this is a fan fiction and I will release
the fan fiction uh to every single
person that votes this movie fresh like
long time listeners of our podcast will
know Jacqueline's affinity for sports
themed erotica that she reads on beaches
from here to the other side of the world
I've seen her travel schedule
there's a lot of frequent fire you're
going to have a good time in first class
with a bottle of Chardonnay and some
rocky Apollo love making fan fiction I
think people would be down for it I'm
not kidding you there's so many like gay
undertones to this yeah but you might
get the critic meter go up and then the
audience meters
change the movie I'm just bribing people
who do care about that level of nonsense
to vote the movie up because let's be
real they're not in the 35 Camp those
were in the 65 camp this may bring them
over to our side this is Outreach okay
all right this is Outreach this is not
trying to take anything away from the
movie the movie exists on its own this
is just for the dark corners of the
internet where we like to play
the movie does the movie does steer you
in a lot of different it can take your
brain and say oh well what if we tackle
that threat or if what if we walk down
this Rabbit Hole where we ultimately end
up is Russia and a convincing Victory by
Rocky Balboa and he does manage to win
over the Russian crowd that night
because they just see the heart of a
champion they start chanting Rocky
certain members of the politburo just
kind of stand and clap whether it's for
political reasons or they're genuinely
moved the director's Cup by the way they
all just kind of take off the
as in the director's cut there's there's
okay
tangent now the director's cut is a
different movie man I mean you get the
the same outcomes in the fights
obviously but there are full scenes that
are put in that we've never seen before
and there's full scenes taken out
there's a great discussion between Rocky
and Apollo about aging and about where
Apollo's been and how Apollo doesn't
feel relevant anymore and stallion
because he's the heavyweight champion of
the world currently can't identify with
what Apollo is going through because
Apollo has always been a few a little
bit further in his career and so he's
like no dude when you get to be me
you're going to understand what I'm
talking about and it's just real
emotional stuff it's like really well
done and in and when we put that in what
do we take out we take out some of the
silliness with Paulie's birthday sure
the robot yeah you can easily cut that
out yeah and the robot was in the movie
as Tim alluded to for two reasons one
it's the 80s and robots for the future
yeah two it's because apparently that
robot was was able to help impact still
want to still own sons who was dealing
with autism and so it was a way to reach
through to that kid and so Stallone's
like well yeah this is great let's put
it in the movie and so now Paulie turns
it into this hot voiced yeah fetching
sex robot look it's an account you're
talking about fan fiction what did
Paulie and that robot do I was just
about to say honestly every piece of fan
every piece of uh I don't know media
would be better improved with a fan
fiction overlay of just a little bit of
dirty writing I'm telling you it all
gets better but it was an accommodation
tool for an autistic kid that also
became an accommodation tool for Paulie
who was like also coded autistic he's
grumpy he doesn't like people he wants
to be on his own and he's very
particular about the food that he eats
dude give that guy something liking
trains and he's Sheldon from The Big
Bang Theory oh he's just a crotchety old
man or he's just a crotchety old man
coated again coded did Adrian help or
hurt this this movie as far as Rocky's
performance in the final fight because
she doesn't want him to go she's all by
the way this is the woman she's always
stood by his side this is the same human
being who woke up from a coma towards
and Rocky II and the first thing she
said just win go win right go kick his
ass right now and so we know Adrian's in
it for the long haul she is insulted by
clever Wang and Rocky III so obviously
wouldn't kicked that guy's ass get some
Revenge there but she wrote on one Rocky
to go she doesn't I want Rocky to go to
Russia Apollo got killed right in front
of her
reservations but then as producer Brian
just alerted me to she does in fact meet
Rocky in Russia where's there so we
don't know where their son is no he's
probably being watched him he's watching
the fight later on yeah with two friends
so there doesn't seem to be a parental
figure involved but here's why I asked
the question about Adrian I love it I
love the character of Adrian but he
clearly went to Russia early to get
minimalists to just have his training
team around you two have other people in
your lives there's dare I say the word
love
uh what does it do to you if you go to
Russia to go fight this guy you just
want Soul focus and then your partner
shows up unannounced maybe a week two
weeks before the fight are you happy
about it are you secretly like what do
you do you're you're ruining the routine
I like that you're asking for my genuine
reaction to first off I'm the World
Heavyweight yeah second I saw my best
friend get murdered in the ring by this
dude and now I've flown across the world
to go trade and my wife suddenly shows
up just how I feel I guess pretty good
considering I'm facing my own mortality
considering this guy just killed my best
friend it's gonna ruin your focus yeah
maybe it helps there's a lot of yeses
that I have to go through to get there
and I don't know if I can make the
mental leap okay maybe this is just me
trying to rationalize my decision to
live alone and live a life of celibacy
the rest of my life if your dog showed
up and you weren't expecting it would it
throw you off yes it would break my
trainings now I gotta take her around
she's out there running with you you
guys are climbing the mountain together
you stand up you're holding her above
your head like Simba at the top of the
mountain I'm getting Hearts on Fire Head
kicked in by Ivan Drago and it's because
the announcer is saying well yeah he
wasn't getting good sleep the last
couple weeks because his Dragon snoring
dog kept waking him up every two hours I
mean I don't know a little cpaper no
it's a Partners out there don't show up
unannounced with a couple weeks left in
training Let Them Fight the fight show
for the fight if you want okay yeah show
up with the fight if you want okay I see
what you're saying like I do want to be
more fault in her decisions yes but also
I couldn't have even like I would have
never gotten to the point of boarding
the plane when your partner is like
don't go and you're like I gotta do what
I gotta do like that is the leap I can't
get the question I was going to ask does
rocky make a convincing enough argument
to pull this thing off with to anybody
no because it's rational for choosing to
do it his rationale it it's and I love
this movie but it's because he's trying
to talk Apollo out he's like we're not
the same guys you know and so we can't
do that and so Apollo goes and he sees
what happens to Apollo and then all of a
sudden Rocky has this thing turned where
he's arguing with on the staircase with
Adrian at his house and he's like
because I'm a fighter it's one of my
favorite lines in the movie when she
said why do you have to do this because
I'm a fighter so did apologist remind
Rocky who Rocky really was all along or
was this Rocky just so incense with
Revenge because I I think it's just more
he just realized oh yeah this is the
thing I'm good at well I mean if it's
Revenge I don't know that he emotes that
where you see the Rage of wanting to get
the satisfaction of you know getting
back this guy the eye of the tiger yeah
but you would assume they'd have to be
part of the motivation maybe it's also
the I don't want this guy stealing the
Thunder of what I've got uh I don't know
that's a good question because you don't
see it on the screen no and Rocky was it
he was on the top of the world I mean it
was sad that he lost his trailer but
mick how many years did Mick have left
anyway so clever Wang gets knocked out
by Rocky and he wins and he's
heavyweight champion of the world and
he's he's on cloud nine
and then I think he's just a guy who now
can still fight at the same level he
used to but he just needs Supreme
motivation it's not just he doesn't I
never saw Rockies that like Michael
Jordan Kobe Bryant level of competitor
where he's just an assassin who needs to
rip your heart out every time he wakes
up I feel like Rocky needs the proper
motivation I feel like Apollo Creed
dying did that yeah I wonder I'm not
even kidding you
an ego like just just guilt just
survivor's guilt oh The Guild is
interesting like it's just it's just
survivor he's fighting himself in that
ring in Russia he's he's like I knew he
shouldn't have done this and I let him
do it anyway the only way I can make it
right is to hurt the person yeah she
holds back throwing the Talon because
he's holding that towels for a while
yeah I just think it survivors and
honestly that's the through line that
you take all the way into Creed for why
he also agrees to Apollo is he still
even after what he thought was gonna
make him feel whole
getting back at Drago he still feels
guilty the point where Apollo's a
legitimate kid comes knocking on his
door he still feels the debt needs to be
paid he still holds it yeah and they
just have that like I think it's just
that they don't have any pictures that's
right it's a point in in Creed too which
is one of my favorite scenes in any film
in this franchise is when Drago shows up
at Rocky's restaurant he's looking at
all the pictures and he's like you don't
have any pictures of our fight and
Rocky's like I didn't really want to
remember it yeah and it's like ooh let's
go everything about Creed 2 made Rocky
for so much yeah exactly exactly because
you also get like that you get a
sympathetic side of Drago that I it
wouldn't have paid off the same way if
this movie came out five or 15 years
after Rocky IV you needed all of this
time to really let I think us heal our
wounds from the cold war and like get
other I don't know International batty
countries in front of Russia and then we
see Creed too and it's like maybe these
guys did change just a little bit maybe
maybe Drago did have one ear listening
to Rocky's speech at the end of this
movie well it seemed like because when
he turns to the polar bear and just like
I'm fighting for me this isn't about the
collective anymore so you can't come
down here and bark at me type of he had
already changed in that moment yeah yeah
and he paid the price for it afterwards
because that's what we find out in Creed
2 is like he paid a very heavy penalty
one for losing and also for his
Disobedience and I'll say I was going to
ask you all this before we move on to
like kind of ranking the Rocky movies in
general is is there any other maybe it's
a performance it's a line at some other
sneaky moment in Rocky IV that really
grabs you because she's great in the
movie in the limited time she hasn't she
has even less time in the director's cut
not sure what happened there but Tony
Burton the actor who just passed away
not too long ago as duke the trainer
formerly Apollo Creed's trainer now he's
training Rocky he is great in this when
he is giving Rocky just that quiet
little pep talk the night before
training really begins and he's like
you're gonna have to go through hell but
if you do I promise you'll be at the end
you'll be the one standing like just
everything Duke does in this movie is
perfect yeah
yeah he's grading it actually you get a
little bit more from Paulie than you
have in previous films that was the one
I was going to go to yeah a little bit
of heart he opens up if I could unzip
myself and step out and be anyone else
it'd be you right before Rocky fights
he's kind of like sorry I've been an
he's like hey this
is that all right yeah
but uh I think Dolph actually yeah being
able to pull off what should be a
caricature villain and there seems to be
some sort of levels to it where it's not
just this cut and paste kind of bad guy
that you would anticipate from an 80s
movie like this especially for an action
film disguised as a boxing movie uh
there's some subtlety to that which on
upon a re-watch kind of surprised it was
like that's better performance than I
remember yeah he's really smart uh
that's the other thing that's most
surprising me about that I actually did
our Creed to junket for us here and like
Dolph Lundgren's a genius like a
legitimate genius PhD candidate yeah
definitely um I actually though was it
was Paulie like the softening of Paulie
towards the end of this this film is
really adorable and also his thing with
the robot like they were comic relief
and I'm not saying that I would be like
sad if it didn't have it in there but
there was an unthawing there and I do
think that that is a little bit coded
more than crotchety because crotchety
does an unthaw that and the movie I I
will defend the robot's appearance in in
the movie in the original cut because
again none the director's cut at all but
I think it does serve a legit purpose
because you're seeing how spoiled you do
get once you have everything you've ever
wanted and the height of everything you
ever wanted in the 80s was I wanted my
own robot so you won all these
championships you have all this money
and the same could be said for Apollo
Creed because we see him chilling with
his dogs in his pool in his mansion and
so they're just living living the dream
but you're not in that pit of hate that
Florian was born into that Ivan Drago
emerged from and so you just don't have
the same desire the Same Heart until you
get that eye the tiger back and for
Rocky unfortunately for Apollo that was
seeing him die in the ring so uh in case
you didn't know no longer with us and I
gave a speech in college uh one of my
one of my public speaking classes we had
to give a speech on a historical figure
and I without asking permission I got an
A on it I just gave a speech on Apollo
Creed and how he was the greatest
heavyweight champion of all time and I
guess I pulled it off okay because in my
speech I made a girl cry when she the
the look of shock on her face when I
said that he died in the ring at the
hands of the Towering Russian Ivan Drago
she was like it was I was like oh I'm
killing this thing oh man and then a
comic was born ladies and gentlemen I I
like the power being Prime and audience
fun stuff comic was born so I think the
real hate we've all been kind of leading
up to here Matt nost is your ranking of
the Rocky movies and we're putting the
Creed films in there as well so all the
Rockies all the Creeds including Rocky 5
Rocky Balboa all that stuff where is
Rocky 4 and if it's not at the top of
the mountain what is for you it's at the
top of the mountain Rocky Forest Rocky
Force the best Rocky movie that they
made wow look you're talking to
six-year-old me who for forever will say
that is the greatest boxing movie I've
ever seen so it's my favorite it's the
most rewatchable I will happily watch it
again right now everybody I haven't seen
the director Scott treat yourself
everybody out there listening it really
is a different movie darker tone more in
depth Dolph Lundgren has a lot more to
say actually oh okay yeah I'll check
this out then yeah Numero Uno is there a
close second for you is there a content
is it green too
uh but no is that great too uh I don't
know maybe three maybe I actually kind
of liked uh what was it Balboa Rocky
Balboa it's good yeah it's Balboa okay
wow uh that one was interesting yeah no
I like it more than rocky five Rocky
five always follows the bottom as the
bottom of my list without question
um I I don't remember how you screw up
Don King that heart is beyond me George
Washington Duke yeah he's a great actor
I don't know why that was the choice I
feel it if Rocky five had was not named
Rocky it was just like a movie about a
guy who like kind of felt like he got
double crossed by his Protege it's not
the worst film I've ever seen it's just
in a Rocky movie it just especially
coming off of Rocky IV and that
triumphant USA kind of thing it had to
morph into something else it just
morphed into something that maybe we
just could have left it a Rocky IV and
then still had the comeback fight with
Rocky Balboa all those years later there
is a cool scene though the beginning of
Rocky 5 where it's like him right after
the fight yeah I do remember that and
he's just kind of sitting there and it's
like oh I think he's got seats t or
something like that apparently
didn't came out of the ring 15 years
later this fight but it was it was tough
that's another performance we should
award as the ref on that because I don't
know what the rules of this fight were
in the second round he goes down to his
knee and instantly stands up and the ref
is like no harm no Falco yeah I'm pretty
sure he's gets a standing eight
no they're definitely not doing a
concussion protocol at that point
they're like if he dies he dies come on
can he walk he's fine
all right what's your uh what's your
number one I mean because for me it
could be the first it could be this one
I could be like Matt knows it could also
be either one of the first two Rockies
it could be the first Creed movie so I
would definitely put Rocky number one
and this is the reason why because uh
the first Rocky in addition to being a
really great uh rags to riches story is
just scored and cinematically filmed in
a way that I just find just kind of
gripping like the Philadelphia uh moment
scene like that's like the part that you
pay attention to but there's an entire
lead up to that that is like
legitimately again just like incredible
Cinema it's better than Tony walking
down on Saturday Night Live it's better
than the Chariots of Fire it really like
puts you into this Hometown here it's
Belle at the beginning of Beauty and the
Beast like you're learning the city
you're learning all of that it is so
much an I want song um there goes the
cheese stick guy with
there's the thing about Rocky movies
their ballads their Ballads of Heroes
like that's what they are and so I find
the ones that feel like a ballad the
ones that I enjoy the most so that would
be the first Rocky the first Creed the
two and three and then also Rocky IV so
all of those get a lot higher than me
than I would just say five and Balboa
which are not ballad to me yeah I found
out courtesy of producer Brian this
morning that uh Bill Conti who did the
music for the first two Rocky films was
not able to come back because he was
working on the first two Karate Kid
movies so you have a different score
it's much more of its time with Survivor
doing not only the by the Tiger but also
Burning Heart and then yeah John
Cafferty and you had you know Robert
Tepper and some Frank Stallone in there
as well in Rocky III and Rocky IV I mean
if you can get them you do yeah
you do that's a problem the schedule
being busy yeah if you can get them it's
a big if but if you still if you're
going to the gym and you listen to this
podcast right now keep listening to the
podcast do all the rating review and all
that good stuff we love but right before
you hit the gym turn this off and put on
Vince dicola's War which is the theme
that they do the two different montages
melded together where you get to see
Rocky's rudimentary training style and
Drago's Advanced Techniques and it leads
all the way up to the crescendo where he
is on the top of a mountain yelling
Drago it's ooh it's good good stuff like
if you can hear him yeah but that was so
quick at the ready so did you listen to
that working out today just about every
day of my life I listened to Vince the
coals I need to find something that
motivates me better in the gym because
honestly it's just perfunctory one of
the things I'd do it because I have to
one of the things recently that's done
it for me was you and I got to see an
advanced screening of Creed 3 yeah which
drops in theaters next week and it's
just every time I get into the theater
to see one of those things the way it's
shot in IMAX uh Michael B Jordan May
King's directorial debut and stepping
back into the ring literally against
just a guy who was just on such a streak
right now Jonathan Majors what a great
villainous presence but there's a lot
more to it than just like this Ivan
Drago sort of statue yes and I will say
I don't think this Creed installment is
necessarily looking to like reinvent the
wheel but if you're looking for just a
Creed movie that I think you're going to
be able to sit down and watch and enjoy
and have moments that really sort of
speak to you I really think this is uh
this is definitely going to be the one
that that folks are going to find I
guess a lot of fun with it
all right so Matt knows the last word
goes to you about Rocky IV all right you
got the you're now you're you're an old
gray man this is some many decades in
the future you mean right now you're
sitting around have you seen my beard
not in spirit we know you're already in
the home in spirit someone did that to
me the other day you might want to
update that picture buddy
[Applause]
[Music]
this gray one comes you get the razor
start shaving again like I did
um what are you telling the kids like
like what is what is it about Rocky 4
that makes it special
uh
uh God I wonder if it's one of those you
need to see it at a specific age because
if I showed it to somebody now who's an
adult it's like I showed my wife a
labyrinth and I figured that'd be a safe
bet because she was like that was so
boring I I didn't enjoy that at all and
I was like wow really I've never seen it
never seen it and uh and that's the
woman you want showing up two weeks
before you fight dragons
just the unvarnished truth that's what I
did that is going to be nodding along in
the barn as you do sit-ups I think this
this might be a case of you need to
indoctrinate the kids early
uh on a movie like this but if you just
want something that's unabashedly
enjoyable fun it's not trying to
reinvent the wheel it's not trying to
make this is not an Oscar caliber movie
nor did they set out to do it even
though previous history with the
franchise that was the case but they
have morphed on because of everything in
the 80s this basically arms race between
him and Schwarzenegger was who get the
biggest box office and the most muscles
and it's a product of its time if you
know that going into it I think it's
phenomenal it is just pure enjoyment
that's all it is yeah and you know you
go back and and I go back to Creed 2
just to say that I think that that movie
impressed a lot of people with how well
it was able to pull off the lore that
you can be critical about Rocky IV you
can say it's cheesy you can say it's
just a montage movie it's a glorified
music video whatever you want to say
about it I think that Creed 2 impressed
a lot of people with oh they took that
backstory and they weaved it into
something that actually did feel real
and and vital and and I actually cared
about these characters so hats off to
Rocky 4 for that so you never know you
can you can bury mythology and then
sometimes it'll come back in a way that
emotionally surprises you uh that's
gonna do it for movie talk today we
don't have a mailbag so we're just gonna
go right to close Brian you wanna hit
some music anyway for us
[Music]
Matt noticed always a pleasure to have
you in the building good to see you face
to face it's good to see you bud to
smell your musk to look at your beard
you're wise grizzled beard
Evergreen beard
uh so this shows I mean it's the fact of
life I want to save a couple more
minutes for you to kind of tell the
audience about settle the score because
yo you're you're missing out if you
don't check this show out on YouTube it
is so much fun to compete in but it's
also just fun to watch because everybody
at home is going to know at least a
couple of these scores we talk about the
Rockies score you know that but
sometimes if you just hear it you're
like oh God I know that what's it from
that's the mountain you have to climb to
win subtle the score uh yeah we tailored
to whoever comes on so if you came on
you're like listen I want fan fiction
specific authors like no problem I will
find the movies that work for that we'll
catch you so we tailor it to the players
because the whole point of the Joe is
like we're just here to have fun we're
not trying to prove who's the greatest
of all times like I have no need of that
I just want to enjoy myself and it's
three rounds and depending on what the
round is uh you're either gonna get a
score or a soundtrack and we give you a
clue and then my uh my partner plays the
piano and he's phenomenal nice he's
phenomenal and
and the best is I will find stuff where
I'm like I cannot wait to hear you do
this like uh the German version of Major
Tom from Atomic blonde we did that where
he sings them all in German wow and he's
like you're an but he learned it
and it's great are you saying it in
Germany in German oh wow and I've done
other ones too and I also like uh uh
shake your ass from About a Boy and it's
like I can't wait to watch you rap let's
do this he's an English kid you know
from London nice
um and I say kid we're roughly the same
age he's got a sweet young thing yeah he
doesn't have all the Grays that I do uh
but it's so I give a clue and then he
starts playing the piano and you're
guessing the movie and that's all it is
there's three rounds and it's just meant
to have a bunch of fun that's the entire
just in point I feel like Jacqueline
would be a lot of the same caliber
player that I am because I'll have some
nice pulls in any given game but there's
also at least one where like I missed I
miss a Star Wars one last
sometimes you're just like
guys this and then this happens and yeah
totally yeah I get it there's always a
blind spot but yeah try and tailor the
show to where you don't walk away with
five of those because then the person's
frustrated and she's like what was the
fun in that for them yeah I don't want
that I don't want to stump them every
time and be like they don't look like an
yes we've had Brian on
what are the things that you're good at
and he said here they are and he lost oh
no producer Brian yeah him his two
partners on their show and they're
really good at the games I was like
Brian we want you to win this one I'm
not going to tell them we're doing this
in advance give me your genres give me
your directors and then I tailored it to
him I still well that's why it's you're
not being a hundred percent
yeah Andy loves the competition and he
wants everybody to have a good time
there's part of Matt notes that going
back to your Rocky and Bullwinkle
reference earlier he's got a little
Snidely whip watch in him he's got a
little mustache tomorrow yes always with
me whether I'm playing subtle the score
look we've known each other since with
the fat iterations of ourselves we speak
bad alcoholics together so we carry a
lot of baggage that uh Hey I was on
vacation do that with you it's fun and
jovial him I'm gonna take it he will
eventually yeah that's okay if we became
good enough friends yes I would I mean
look I know I don't mind it I was raised
by a woman so let's be real
uh you're also a fantastic stand-up
comedian uh so for upcoming tour dates
check out mad no saw in all his social
platforms and congrats on a great run
with uh your show top 10 your podcast
with our buddy John Roca finally coming
to an end after eight years all All
Things Must Pass and so yeah wow what
was the final top 10 list you did uh
well this comes out Thursday yeah uh
we're not doing it till Monday oh it's a
tease as per usual look at him his
Show's ending and he's still not giving
us it so we got it too much gotta tune
in all right well I can't at least ask
you for this then do you have a movie TV
show that you uh are enjoying currently
that you saw recently you want to
recommend all the kids out there
you know uh Last of Us I started gold
that's pretty good from BBC
Stonehouse is a three-parter that was
interesting another BBC show all right
you're getting it I already know my
wife's a sucker for anything English so
we're always on the hunt for any kind of
English nice nice uh so those outside of
Last of Us that's what I've been
watching that and Godfather of Harlem my
god oh I love God I've done a bunch of
stuff with that show The Last of Us
nobody watches that show though he is
Forest Whitaker is so good in that show
that's a really like Well Done show it's
a lot of shows a lot of shows to watch
yeah there's so much a lot of content
hot take from Mark is uh we say good
night here on Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
we love when we do get mailbags though
we just didn't have time for it today so
email us RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
whatever your platform of choice
encourages you to do for podcasts you
like do it for us because not only do
you like us you'll love us and if I died
in the ring you would avenge me in
Russia on Christmas day next week's
episode Jacqueline what do we got who we
talking to what are we talking about
we're getting dark yes gonna take it to
the
to this so bad please talk like that the
entire episode oh God who is that give
me that that prudish NPR girl I I don't
like her she's she she peeks her head
out no we're doing our After Dark
episodes which is basically whatever
happens it to come into our mind all
right we'll just talk it through maybe
we'll have a special guest for that yes
I don't yes we'll have a special I'd be
very familiar especially it might be
very familiar an incredibly familiar
special guest
tell you this is we don't ever do this
our special guest will be returning a
returning special guest yeah okay yeah a
returning Champion a returning Champion
yeah there you go back to defend their
belt who's it going to be
that's why we do it all right for
Jacqueline for Matt for Glenn for Remsen
for Brian the producer who lost even
though he had a huge leg up in his most
recent set of the score appearance the
whole game matters I'm mark ellisank
thank you and we will see you next week
[Music]
thank you